Hello and welcome to Python Bytes where we deliver Python news and headlines directly to your earbuds.
This is episode 262 recorded December 8th, 2021. Oh my gosh, it's almost winter. I'm Michael Kennedy.
And I'm Brian Okken.
And I'm Leah Cole.
Yay.
Yay. So great to have you here. Thanks for being here on the show.
Yeah. Happy to be here.
You and I got a chance to discuss Airflow over on Talk Python a couple months ago, something like that.
Yeah.
- Yeah, but now we'll probably do a little more Airflow
over here for people who are unfamiliar with that,
but also just whatever you're interested in.
So great to have you here.
Why don't you tell people a quick bit about yourself
before we jump into the topics?
- Sure, so I'm Leah,
and I am a developer relations engineer in Google Cloud.
And specifically, I work on Cloud Composer,
which is our hosted managed product
of the popular Apache Airflow project,
which we'll talk about a little bit later.
And in addition to writing samples and content for that,
I also work with a group of fellow engineers
and we maintain all Python samples for Google Cloud
and make sure that they stay tested, up to date,
and are healthy and are getting reviewed for new samples.
And that's a lot of fun.
That kind of fell into my lap and has been a good time.
- That's fantastic.
I remember Python being one of the original
two supported languages on Google Cloud, right?
It had sort of a special place.
- Yeah, now it's one of seven, I think.
- Yeah, cool.
Well, that sounds like such a fun job.
I've always imagined dev relations type of jobs
to be super fun, maybe slightly less fun in COVID
'cause the travel and the conferences
and all those kinds of things are a part of it,
but still a fun job, right?
- Still a good time.
Every day is a little bit different.
You kind of never know what's gonna happen
and that's part of what I like about it.
- Yeah, awesome.
Oh, cool.
Brian, I don't even know what you're gonna cover,
so I don't know what's gonna happen.
Why don't you let us know?
- You don't know what I'm gonna cover?
- I, well, I'm not looking at my docs yet.
- Oh, okay.
(laughing)
Sorry, fighting a cold.
I am super excited,
PyTest 7, release candidate one, is out.
So--
- Oh, that's excellent.
That's big news.
- It is.
The last release for PyTest was, or six,
they've done other dot releases,
but the six two, or six zero came out,
or six two, I don't know, I lost track.
- We use six two four for our GCP samples, so.
- Oh, you do?
- We do.
- So the, this, I think it was, I wrote this down.
The 6.2.0 was released on December, 2020.
So it's been, we're ready for a new one.
So 7.0 is out, the release candidate at least.
And so, because it's a release candidate to install it,
you have to do a pip install pytest,
double equal 7.0.0 rc1.
We've got that in the show notes.
It's also on the release announcement page for pytest.
but I wanted to go through some of the cool features
that I'm really excited about.
There's a lot of great things in there.
There's some little improvements with the approx thing.
So one of the things that PyTest has is an approx.
So you can say floating point numbers,
if you're comparing them, you should never do equal,
but you can do equal approx with PyTest
and it's really pretty cool.
- That's cool, I didn't know that
because any science you're doing is so,
like double equals is the kiss of death
for floating point math comparison.
- Yeah, well, the PyTest of Procs
does now the docs reference the NumPy comparisons,
which is nice because NumPy
has some really cool features around that.
But PyTest out of the box does.
And now also with mappings and dicts and other sets,
it handles decimal types, which is nice.
Decimal types, of course, are very useful
when working with money and other things
that need to be exact decimals.
One of the things that's really cool
is the sequences are compared better.
So if you have like a list of numbers
and you compare against an approximate list
of another numbers, I didn't know you could do this,
it will tell you which index was wrong
and by how much. - Oh, nice.
- And actually not by how much,
but what the expected was, and that's pretty neat.
So those are the little minor features.
Most of these are kind of minor,
but it made your first somebody, right?
So one of the things I like is
some people have mentioned fixtures
or sometimes when people use a lot of fixtures,
they don't know where the fixtures are.
Well, there's a couple of flags,
fixtures per test and dash dash fixtures.
There's, both those flags are helpful to find out
what fixtures you have available.
And now by default, they print the location of the path
in with the fixture name.
And you can also do a verbose option
that prints out the full doc string,
which is pretty handy.
The couple of things that I'm really excited about
are Python path that's been added.
And that was a feature I added to the project,
which is fun.
- Nice.
It's cool to see the contributions you're making
coming back out.
- Yeah, it's cool.
And then there's a bunch of other features
that I contributed to by just saying,
"This is a little weird.
"Can we fix this?"
And somebody else volunteered to fix it.
So it's nice.
- That's the best kind of contribution.
(laughing)
- Yeah.
One of the improvements in the docs,
which is kind of fun, is there's an auto-generated list of,
so I've got the changelog going on here.
And I gotta come back to this.
There's an auto-generated list of plugins
and there's 963 right now.
We'll refresh it.
Nope, still 963.
But that's a lot.
When I first started writing the beta
or the second edition of the PyTest book,
I noticed this and I wrote it down,
but the number keeps changing.
So I took out the number.
I'm like, it's a lot.
There's a lot of cool plugins.
One of the things that if you'll notice
when you go to the change log,
it starts with breaking changes and then deprecations.
And I know, I think this is around
because people, when they upgrade,
they wanna know if it's gonna break their code or not.
I have tested a bunch of stuff and upgraded from six to seven
and I haven't noticed a lot.
There was like a six one to six two.
I can't remember what the,
There was one break a while ago in the 6X
that messed some plugin authors,
but I haven't noticed any problems.
So please try these out.
I wish they would do the features first
and then not the breaking changes,
'cause that's-- - I suspect it's the
people working deep in the guts,
like the plugin authors, that hit these deprecations
and not just people doing assert this equals that
type of work. - Yeah, yep, right.
One of the things that I didn't list,
but I think a lot of people are excited about,
There's more, the objects within PyTest
that people are using, more of them are type hinted now
so that you can do type hints with objects.
- Oh, that's nice.
- Yeah. - Yeah, that's really nice.
- So, fun.
- Leah, do you use PyTest?
Some of these changes exciting?
- We do, we use PyTest on our Python samples.
And so I, actually the one that was most exciting to me
was the fixtures, figuring out where fixtures are
is definitely something that comes into play for me,
especially when we're maintaining something
that was written a while ago by someone
who might not be working on that code anymore.
- Yeah. - Yeah.
- Nice. - Yeah.
- That's cool. - This is great.
I love the pip installable RC1, that's great.
And before we move on, let's take a step back.
Roman Wright, author of Beanie.
Hey, Roman, out there in the audience says,
"Hey, I'm a big fan of Google Cloud."
- Oh, thank you. - For sure.
Well, I've got some fun stuff to talk about next here.
I want to talk about this thing that David Smith,
former guest co-host here on Python Bytes sent over and said,
"This looks cool."
Sam Lowe and Philip Guell released this thing
called Pandas Tutor.
- This is cool.
- Yeah, previously, Philip had built Python Tutor
at pythontutor.com.
Now there's pandastutor.com.
And it's all about just helping you understand
what the code does.
So it basically says, look, there's this code here.
Like imagine you've got a list of dogs
that have a breed, a type, a longevity,
a type is like a herding dog or a toy dog,
it goes in a purse.
Longevity, size, weight, and so on.
And you've got that as a data frame.
If you wrote dogs with a size equal equal medium,
then sort values on type, then group by by type,
and then show the median,
well, what is that actually doing?
Like, how do I understand that, right?
As somebody learning pandas,
imagine I don't really have a database background,
and so I'm not sort of trying to map that over
to like, okay, there's the where clause,
there's the order by clause,
and you know, like that kind of business, right?
So what is happening when I write that code,
either because I'm coming across it for the first time,
or, which happens to me a lot,
I wrote it two years ago and understood it perfectly then.
I have no idea what it does now, right?
You wanna know what it does. - Oh, same.
- Yeah, that happens way too often, right?
So what you do is you can go and run this code
over in Pandas Tutor, and you say visualize,
and it says running a code, please wait.
And so what they do is they put a CSV bit of text in here,
it's like a triple string,
and then use pandas read and then just do that one line.
So that's a nice way to kind of get data in there.
And the way to think about this is steps.
It shows you what is the first step
and what is the second step and so on.
So when you go there,
you'll see that it has the code that we were talking about,
but then right now the effective where clause,
the filter is regular font and the rest is gray.
It's like fade into the background.
And so you can actually see what the starting data frame was
and the ending data frame, and then how it got in there.
And you can use the mouse over like,
so what they're saying is the type is medium.
So if you hover over like a large or a small dog,
there's just no arrow.
But if you hover over medium,
it shows you where in the result that that thing landed.
Isn't that cool?
- That's wild.
- Isn't that wild?
And so then you can see size has all the values on the left
and then the size is grouped on the right
and it shows medium, medium, medium, medium,
because that's all that's in there.
Now, when I first looked at this, I'm like,
there's a bunch of stuff on the screen, what's going on?
I noticed the arrows, but then what it took me a minute to realize is there's multiple steps.
So the next thing if you scroll down, shows the same code at the top,
but now the sort values type is highlighted.
That's the next part of what looks like one expression in Pandas.
And so now it highlights the column that it's sorting on,
and you can actually see the arrows pointing to how they were reordered in the result,
because you're sorting by type, so it's non-sporting, non-sporting, non-sporting, non-sporting,
and then sporting, sporting, and working, working, and so on.
So that was step two.
And we have a group by this one's interesting.
It said have arrows as colors.
So the group by type again, non-sporting, sporting, so on.
You end up with these groups, like here's a blue,
a blue box of all the non-sporting dogs,
the bulldog, the poodle, the French bulldog is so cute.
Then you've got the golden retriever
and the Labrador and the boxer, right?
So these are grouped into the colors.
And then finally you do the median
and it shows how those groups reduce down to statistics,
Like the longevity of a non-sporting dog is less than a sporting dog, apparently,
but they're also lighter.
So anyway, what do you all think?
Oh my gosh.
I love this.
This is nice, right?
I'm a very visual learner, so I really appreciate this.
And especially if you're working with data that you kind of aren't sure what it
does and or the code, like that's pretty incredible.
I'm filing this away.
It's going to go to my team's group chat pretty much as soon as we're done
recording.
In fact, yeah, that's awesome.
I think it's really good.
There's so many people who are presented a notebook
or presented some kind of result,
and they're like, I need to understand what that means
so I can keep following it.
And I think, throw it into here,
something like this would be really helpful.
- Well, and a lot of people that have spent a lot of time
with databases, it might be obvious what these things do.
But for people that don't spend a lot of time with SQL,
it's not obvious.
And so this is really nice.
- Yeah, definitely.
Or if you're like trying to take some example
that you have with their example data
and trying to translate it to your own data.
That's something that customers do all the time for us.
It's something I do a lot too.
Just seeing how it behaves with your stuff.
Oh man.
- You didn't write it, but you wanna use it.
So how much applies.
- Exactly.
- Yeah, so this is quite cool.
Dean out in the live stream.
Hey Dean, says Panda's tutor looks awesome.
And Robert Robertson also loving it.
It's nice.
So very cool.
Indeed. All right. Over to you, Leah.
All right. So yeah, my first thing today is Apache Airflow.
So Airflow is a project that is part of the Apache Software Foundation.
It's a workflow orchestration tool that originated at Airbnb,
I want to say in like 2014,
and then pretty shortly after became part of the ASF
and it became a top level Apache project
in, I want to say early 2019.
It's been a little while now, which is very exciting.
So you can use it to author these workflows
as directed acyclic graphs or DAGs of tasks,
which is pretty cool.
And it's most commonly used with workflows
that are like pretty static,
not super frequently changing or slowly changing,
just so that you can see how the workflow goes over time
and not allows you for some clarity
and continuity in your workflows.
- I've always sort of wondered
what the role of these workflow type systems were
And until I realized, you know, if you're going to build a full end to end
type of workflow without a framework, there's a lot of coordination.
And what if this fails?
Where do you restart?
What do you do?
And then the analogy for me is kind of like flask or some web, like all I got
to do is write this little thing and everything else will come together to
make sure these four lines of my Python code run, they run reliably.
If they fail, it gets dealt with, right.
It allows people to not have to understand the whole system and just go, I need you
to load up this file and put it into that database.
Can you write that code?
And that's all you got to know to be part of some complex thing, right?
Yeah, it's, I mean, it's not the most glamorous thing, but it is extremely useful.
I mean, I did a summer internship when I was doing my bachelor's, where I wrote a cron job that ingested some data every night.
And the only way I knew if it failed was if I looked in the target folder where it's supposed to end up and if the data wasn't there.
No files, whoops.
That sucked. I'm sure a lot of people have dealt with that.
And this is actually a really common Airflow workflow,
which is the extract, transform, and load, the ETL workflow,
which is where you have data somewhere that you want to get,
you want to do something to it, or maybe not,
maybe you just want to extract and load it,
and you want to put that result somewhere else,
either locally or in the cloud for all of that.
And Airflow lets you do all of that.
And you can see the history of these jobs.
There's a UI where you can see, did it fail?
It has a full error message if it failed.
It's not just, oh gosh, the data is not there.
What do I do?
>> Yeah. You got a really cool UI where it shows
all the parts of the workflow running and
whether or not they finished successfully and stuff, right?
>> Yeah. It got a makeover fairly recently.
So it's a lot of improvements.
>> Yeah, that's super cool. Another thing maybe you
could talk about really quick is the connectors.
I don't remember exactly the right terminology.
There's a name for them.
tell us, tell people about that. That's also good to know.
So these connectors that you're thinking of,
I mean, we can use the word connector to describe what it does.
So there are these things called operators in Airflow,
and an operator executes a single task.
And so that might be executing a Bash script
or executing a Python script.
But we also have these connectors that are grouped by providers,
which might be your cloud provider or other software
providers that allow you to execute code there.
So for example, we have a ton of GCP operators.
One example might allow you to create a Dataproc cluster
or then like run a job on that Dataproc cluster
and maybe tear it down when you're done.
And there are providers that have operators
for all the major clouds and more.
You can do, there's one that like sends a Slack message when it's done.
So it's, if you can dream it,
it might be there and if not, you can make it there.
That's awesome. What's GCP?
GCP is Google Cloud Platform.
Or Google Cloud.
GCP might be a dated acronym. Sorry.
Don't know.
Yeah.
Yeah. So one of the advantages I think of that,
that's really cool is you don't necessarily have to know all those APIs.
Like if I was going to connect Slack to GCP,
to like Azure Blob Storage,
to like some hosted database,
I don't have to learn all those things.
I can just sort of click it together.
Yeah. You just have to,
there's a small amount of setup you have to do
for auth, which is understandable. You can't just like publicly go to your Azure blob thing
to grab your data. But once you set up that connection, then your operators can talk to
those things. And if you use so you can run or host Airflow yourself. And there are a
few different ways to do that. And then Amazon and Google both have managed hosted providers.
And there's a company Astronomer that also does manage hosted ones. And so if you're
in an Amazon or a Google, the advantage there is that the connections with those operators
might be a little bit simpler from the auth and networking perspective. But other than that,
if you're running in Cloud Composer, which is Google's Airflow, you can still be using the
Amazon or the Microsoft operators to pull data from over there. That's really common. And you
see it all the time and bring it, do some stuff in Google Cloud and either put it back in the
in the other cloud or leave it in Google Cloud.
That's totally normal and people are doing that all the time.
- Right on. - Yeah.
- Cool, cool.
I think this is neat and people for whom that would
make sense, you're like trying to do these
sort of running in the background,
- Yeah. - schedule jobs,
or there's triggers as well.
Like a file has been uploaded or landed here.
- Yeah, let's talk about that.
So that's actually, I had written down this one example,
but I'll adapt it slightly since you mentioned triggers.
So that's another common type of operator,
these sensors where you wait for a certain condition
to be true, and they're used in data analytics workflows
all the time.
So one example workflow might be waiting
for a particular file to appear in a cloud storage or an S3
bucket.
So you'd use one of those sensors
to wait for that to happen.
And then you want to do something to that data.
So let's say you then create a data prod cluster that
is going to run a PySpark job on that cluster.
And then you can store the results in BigQuery at the end
and then delete the cluster and like send a Slack message
when the job is done.
That's a very common ETL thing, including that sensor.
- Yeah, that sounds pretty nice.
Definitely seems interesting and quite useful.
- Yeah, it's a lot of fun.
- Brian, thoughts before we move on?
- I have a question.
If you wanted to get started with something like this,
I was trying to look for tutorials
and getting started and stuff like that.
Is it, does it make sense or is it too confusing
if somebody, you said you could run it on your own machine.
Does that make sense to try it that way
or should you try it with a, okay.
- You totally can do it on your own machine
and there's this really wonderful environment
that can be found in the Airflow repository
that's called Breeze and it's a Dockerized version of it.
It shouldn't be run in production
but if you're looking to try it out
or if you're looking to contribute to Airflow,
we highly recommend that everyone check out
the Breeze environment.
- Right now I have the community page pulled up
where you can join the dev list in the Slack
if you have questions,
but if you were to go to the GitHub repo,
you would see Breeze right on that first page.
- Okay, cool, thanks.
- Yeah, great question, thank you.
- Yeah, very good one.
All right, Brian.
Are you gonna give us a tutorial on Airflow
or what we got going next?
- Yeah, so I was looking through the tutorials in Airflow
and I noticed that right away
one of the examples used ddent.
So that was a nice--
- How about that for a connection?
- Nice connection.
- Totally well planned, very cool.
- D-dent was suggested, it's a text wrap tool,
it's suggested by Michael Rogers-Fallet.
It's a small utility, but it's super useful.
And I kind of forget that it's, I mean,
I use it all the time, but I forget to mention it
to people, but it comes up a lot.
And the idea around D-dent is you've got something,
oh, I think I lost my D-dent thing.
Let's see if I can find it. There it is.
The idea is you've got a multi-line string,
like here we've got "Hello World."
And some multiple lines, and there's different spacing.
But as you notice, I want to define it within a test,
within a test function or within some other function.
And so there's this extra, like, space at the beginning.
That's in the string.
It's in the multi-line string, and we don't want that.
We don't, we want it to be just, just no, like nothing at the beginning or the same amount chopped off.
So one of the options that people have used before is to just define a very multi-line string out of the function.
You just do it out of the function, then it's against, then it's just against the left side of your editor or whatever on column zero,
and you don't have to worry about it.
But it does bother some people that you've got this, this variable defined outside of your function when you're just using it within one function.
So dedent is the answer.
So what dedent does is it just takes a multi-line string
and strips off all the common white space at the beginning.
That's it.
But it's super useful.
They've got a little example that we're showing here,
but I think this is not a great example.
So I wrote a new example.
Oops, fell asleep.
And so the idea really is I've got a function
that either print stuff or has some output,
and I wanna be able to compare that string,
and I want my comparison to be in the function.
So I use ddent to just write it right in my function
and then I don't have the spaces.
And then, yeah, anyway.
So this is a PyTest example
of how you could test a output string.
So anyway.
- This really sounds like a classic example
of there's a problem, like the open source,
this really bothered me.
And so I wrote something to fix it.
And it's wonderful.
Like the time honored open source reason to make something.
But I also want to remind people that D-Dent is not the only thing in TextWrap.
And TextWrap has a whole bunch of other cool tools.
So it's not huge, it's just a five-minute read to peruse what's in TextWrap
so that next time you need to manipulate some text, it's useful.
Nice. Maybe wrapping.
Yeah, like wrapping.
It does things like if you've got a huge string and you want to be able to...
Like one of the things is to shorten it.
So if you've got a huge string,
but you really only have like eight characters to show something.
- Like ellipsize it.
- Yeah, it does that for you.
So that's there too.
- That's good 'cause I've written that code.
It wasn't fun.
(laughing)
It didn't feel useful either.
I'm like, okay, great, it works.
But here we go.
Some audience feedback, Anthony out there.
Hey, Anthony says, "It's really useful.
"Used it many times."
- Nice. - Quite cool.
All right, this next one comes to us from Dan Bader.
You might know him from RealPython and other things.
He and I were chatting and he said,
"Hey, have you heard about PIP audit from Trail of Bits?"
And I was sure that I had,
and I thought we had talked about it,
but then I realized, "No, I don't believe we have."
So I must've just heard about it somewhere else,
and we haven't covered it before.
So the idea is we've heard about a lot of issues
with supply chain vulnerabilities,
things getting into PIP,
but also RubyGems and NPM and so on.
Sometimes that's somebody trying to be evil
and putting in some typo squatting thing,
or worse than that would be
if the GitHub account of a maintainer got hacked
and somebody published a package
with like to the real package, right?
So however things might get into your dependencies,
if something is going on bad there,
it's better to know than to not know.
So this pip audit is all about that.
It audits Python environments as in virtual environments
and dependency trees for known vulnerabilities.
So that's one of the things that's interesting
is when you pip install things,
you might be very good about saying,
"Oh, I pip installed Flask and I pip installed Pandas.
So those are going into my requirements file
or my pyproject.toml,
but did you remember to pin their versions?"
So that things like GitHub will say,
"Your version is wrong."
'Cause if it just sees Flask
and the recent version doesn't have a problem,
it's not gonna tell you,
"But the one you have installed may."
Also the transitive closure of the dependencies.
So Flask depends on it's dangerous,
which depends on, I don't know.
But if there's something down that chain
that has a problem, you may have not put that
in your requirements file and you may not be tracking it.
Like I might be paying careful attention to Flask,
I might not care anything about it's dangerous,
but that's where the problem is, right?
- Yeah.
- So this tool from Trail of Bits,
which is a security company, basically solves that problem.
And it lets you just type pip-audit.
And for me, it's a -r requirements.txt or whatever.
And from what I can tell, what it does is it will go
create its own virtual environment
where it one by one installs each package,
looks at the things that come out of that process
and then scans those.
So it's not just looking at,
oh, you say you have Flask and that's 201,
great, you're good to go.
It actually installs it
because who knows what the setup.py process is doing
and all those kinds of things.
And then it scans that and it gives you a report.
So for like Talk Python Training site,
we have, I don't know, 30 dependencies or something.
and it sat there and it took, I don't know,
probably took two minutes to go through
and it said, "Everything's good to go."
So that was good to hear, but it's pretty neat.
Really easy to use.
It's like an external tool, like Black or something.
So it's a very good candidate for PIPX,
and then it's just globally available
to point at any environment.
What do you all think?
- Oh, this is so cool.
I heard about it 'cause one of my colleagues,
Dustin Ingram, I think has been involved with it,
or either it's his Twitter that I found out about it from,
but he also has a really good talk from PyCon
this past year about the supply chain vulnerabilities
that's worth checking out if you're wanting to get an idea
of why this is important.
- Yeah, yeah, we've highlighted a few examples
over the years, but it's definitely something
you wanna pay attention to.
And that's cool that Dustin was talking about it.
He works, I think he's still working with the PyPA
and works on the pypi.org and all those kinds of things.
So very cool warehouse.
Brian, what do you think?
- I think this is cool, I'm gonna start using it right away.
This is nice.
- Yeah, I already used it once as well
and everything seems good.
So here, look, I even called a flask as an example.
Say here on this particular version,
there was this security vulnerability from 2019
and same with, I guess, Ginger and all those were good.
But yeah, it gives you a nice description
of what went wrong and like in this case,
it's a denial of service attack and whatnot.
- So I definitely recommend people pin versions,
definitely in your requirements.
But what do you all think of including hashes?
- I think that's something Dustin talked about in his talk.
And at the time I was like,
oh, that sounds like a good idea.
And it's not something I've started doing yet.
- Yeah.
- Exactly, that's exactly what I think.
It sounds like a good idea and I'm not doing it yet.
So anyway.
- But that sounds like it's a me problem.
More than anything else.
- I also, it seems like a good idea.
You know, I might be missing a step.
It feels like the, the challenge you're going to run into there, where what you're preventing
against as a man in the middle attack, somebody can intercept what's happening with IPI.org
and sneak in some kind of broken hacked version.
I don't know.
I don't necessarily trust what goes into pipe.org, but I trust pipe.org.
So I'm not super, it's not my biggest worry.
There's like 10 other worries that make me have a hard time sleeping at night about running
stuff on the internet that precedes that.
So I haven't worried about it, but maybe I should.
- It's in the queue of things to worry about.
- Well, for instance, with this audit,
you can pin your stuff and then have it be,
check it every once in a while,
install everything and check things.
- I don't see why it couldn't be a CI step.
- I was actually just gonna say that PIP audit,
I need to bring it to my samples maintaining group
to talk about who wants to implement it
and how soon we're gonna do it.
- And whose pager rings when it finds a problem.
- Yes.
- Yeah, I'm listening to that,
pagers from back in the day.
All right, well, that's all I got for that one.
We're off to Leah.
- I'm so glad you mentioned pitting requirements
because that is actually,
that's a great segue for managing samples for GCP.
So what I have open right now for Google Cloud
is an example documentation page.
I picked Cloud Composer because it's what I work on.
And I wanna give an example
of where this code lives that I'm talking about
that I work with this group to maintain.
So this is a page that's about using
a particular Airflow operator.
And if you were to scroll on it,
you will see these code samples
and they are all stored in GitHub
and then embedded in our docs.
So you can click view on GitHub on any one of them
and it will take you to the linked repository.
You can look at the history,
look at everything in context.
So we have thousands of samples for all of the Google Cloud
products, just for Python.
But we have them in other languages, too.
And they're located across hundreds of repos.
This happens to be one repo that has
samples for multiple products.
But we have other repos where things are stored, too.
So to ensure that there's consistency
and that my group of engineers, my colleagues, and I actually
have time to do our work and function as humans outside of work too, we use a lot of automation.
So we use a lot of bots to do things like keep our dependencies up to date, check for
license headers, auto assign PRs for reviewing, syncing repositories with centralized configurations,
and even more, which is pretty great. And this is actually where the pinning requirements
comes in. We very strongly believe in pinning requirements because it makes the samples
easier to maintain and test against.
And it's easier to go back to the product and say,
"Hey, you just pushed a release candidate for your product
and it broke your samples."
It wasn't supposed to. What gives?
Rather than finding out mysteriously when getting a customer issue.
So then to keep it up to date, we use
a bot and these are some pull requests recently opened by the bot of some
dependencies. They get double checked to make sure everything looks good
by human and merged.
It's pretty great. And then we actually have a team
of engineers in DevRel
that works on making GitHub bots
that we use, and that is totally open source.
You can see some of the ones that we use.
We have our license header one.
The sync repo settings
allows us to have a single source of truth
for our configuration for all of our Python repos.
And then it makes sure it gets synced across all of them.
It's pretty great. I really don't know how I would function without all of my bot friends.
This is super cool. I can just imagine how much work it is to keep all of those different things
in sync. And I have worked recently on projects where I'm like, okay, I got to integrate this
library, I'm going to go to the documentation, and I try to use the one or two functions that
the whole thing does. And it's like, nope, that parameter doesn't exist, or you're missing some
you're like, come on, at least just keep the signature, right?
You know, it's, and of course it's something like star org, star star KW orgs.
It's not like, oh, I can just look in my ID and see, oh yeah, it says it takes like,
use security, use SSL, yes or no.
Like, no, it's unknown without the documentation, basically.
Yeah.
This is awesome.
Thank you.
I think so too.
I'm very grateful to it.
And yeah, for our dependency bot, we do use an external one.
I know, I think GitHub is the one that does depend a bot.
We in particular use White Source Renovate Bot.
It's what we were using when I started
and that works very well too
and they're very nice and responsive to issues.
- Oh, that's fantastic.
Yeah, Dependabot was fairly new
and then it was bought quite recently by GitHub
so I can imagine you were all doing something before then.
- Probably, but I know I have friends who use that too
and they're great.
Using a dependency bot, I would say,
if you need a starter bot for any of them,
the dependency bot is a great place to start.
- Yeah, that's fantastic.
I recently switched to PipTools and PipCompile
to generate my requirements with pinned versions and stuff.
- Nice.
- But before that, I was all about the pinned bot
telling me if something new was out and seeking that.
- Nice.
- Yeah.
- PipTools rocks, I love PipTools.
- Yeah, it definitely does.
Brian, there's a lot of cool automation here.
What do you think?
- I'm excited about looking through all these.
I love looking at bots, 'cause the whole idea about a bot
is to do, is like the Unix philosophy
of do one thing and do it well.
- Yes. - And I love that.
- And have something else do it and not you do it.
- Oh yeah, all of our bots are based on like,
oh gosh, we're doing this one thing over and over
and we're not doing it well because we're doing it manually.
So how can we like use automation
to make sure we're doing it consistently
and just save a lot of time.
- Like one of the things you've got in here
that's shown right now is label sync.
So one of the nice things about,
one of the interesting things
about different groups workflows is to have different labels
that mean different things.
But when you open a new repo,
it doesn't have all those labels.
So being able to sync those labels across an organization.
- Like needs triage, good first contribution,
all those kinds of things, right?
- Yeah, as I said, we have hundreds of repos
just for Python and we use things like we have labels
that say what API something belongs to.
And that helps with the auto assign bot
to make sure that issues and PRs
get routed to the right team.
Otherwise you're having a human do all that triage,
which is fine, but doesn't scale super well in our use case.
- Yeah.
- And adding a label is really easy
to an issue or something.
So having a bot that looks at label changes
and just does an action based on that
is a brilliant use of time.
- Yep.
Highly recommend.
- Yeah, fantastic.
This is great.
- And you have an install link next to all of them.
That mean I just click that
and install it into one of my repos?
- I believe that is the intent.
And if it doesn't work,
you should open an issue on this repo
because my colleagues are very responsive.
- Fantastic.
- Yeah. - And we just need bots
to generate bots.
- Honestly, if my colleagues told me
they were working on that in this repo,
I wouldn't be surprised, but I don't know.
(laughing)
- The meta bot.
- Yeah.
- Fantastic.
All right, well, how about some extras?
Brian, you got anything extra
you want to share while we're here before we call it a show?
- No, just I'm fighting a cold
and hopefully that'll all be over.
- Feel better soon.
- Yeah, maybe some sort of audit thing.
We'll check your health status.
We can run that against you.
Leah, anything else you want to share with us?
- Oh, I mean, on Twitter earlier,
we were talking about HTTP status codes
and it reminded me of still my forever reference
for HTTP status codes is http.cat.
- Yes, http.cat is fantastic.
- It's so good.
- It is so good.
- Let's share a few non-funny things
and then we'll mix that in with our joke.
- Please do.
- Fantastic, all right.
The first one has to do with, speaking of GitHub,
another cool GitHub thing.
You know you could press a dot
and that would do certain things.
This only works if you're signed in.
But now there's a command palette.
This idea of command palettes are becoming popular in UIs.
We've got it in VS Code.
We've got it in like Superhuman, the email.
And often you get them by pressing Command + K
or Control + K, and now you have that for GitHub.
So if I were on a repo where I could do stuff to it,
I could hit Command + K, and then it will say,
what do you wanna do?
Search or jump to, I could go to pages, issues,
I could look for, let's see, look for the app.
If I just type app, it'll search for those.
I could search for all sorts of things here and boom,
it takes me and shows me all the apps.
Isn't that cool?
- That's so cool.
- Command palette, yeah, that's now a thing.
- That's beautiful.
- And you could just, I mean, no mouse.
I'm here, I'm in this repo, the top level,
command K, down arrow, two times to enter,
I'm on the issues.
- Oh my gosh, love to see it.
- Yeah, so that's a good one.
The other one, the other extra,
is Python 3.10.1 is out, released December 6th,
so as in two days ago.
- Wow.
- It's got a fun little snake with a hat on.
- Love it.
- That's really about 3.10.
So let me describe, I can cover the entire release for you.
So Python 3.10.1 is the newest major release
of the Python programming languages.
It contains many features and optimizations.
So now you all know what's in it.
(laughing)
It's very vague.
- It's really vague.
- It's very vague.
(laughing)
Apparently it has 300 commits of changes and fixes.
One thing I would, I wanted to know,
are there security updates?
Yes or no?
Like, should I, like, should I install this if I'm curious
or should I install this now before tomorrow?
because someone's gonna start poking around.
I would love if it would say that.
There's a great thing about the major features,
but that's just 3.10, not the point release.
So anyway, still good.
- Yeah, we've been having fun making all of our GCP samples,
making sure they're 3.10 compatible,
which we're getting there.
It's all waiting for certain dependencies to be ready.
But a lot of fun, very exciting to see.
- Yeah, that's awesome.
- Well, you can look at the change log.
So if you look at the 3.10,
the change log, you can see 310 one and stuff.
- I can.
- Okay, go up a little bit.
- Full change log there maybe?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's true.
I can go to the change log there and check that out.
- But having a security thing would be a good idea.
- Yeah, just like--
- A TLDR.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly, cool.
- Well, and also a lot of people didn't wanna try 310
until we got one patch release.
So now we have one patch release, so there's no excuse.
- So now it's quote safe.
I have been running it for a day in production
and it seems okay.
put it on one site to see if it would hang in there.
It seems fine.
So we're all good.
- Yeah.
All right, the samples that are using it are doing fine.
They've had passing periodic builds for a while.
- Yeah, fantastic.
All right, are you ready for some--
- No, I'm ready. - Chat jokes later?
- Sorry.
- Yes, I mean, we started our conversation off today
talking about cats.
- It's true.
- Before we hit record.
So I feel like we should round that out, yeah?
- Definitely.
- So first of all, httpstatuses.com
is a fantastic place to go learn about the real meaning
or the official meaning, let's say, of status code.
So for example, there's 100 continue,
and if you want details, you click on that,
and it actually pulls this all up.
Even shows you like the enum in Python,
if you wanna use that. - Oh my gosh, I love that.
- Isn't that cool? - Yeah.
- It gives you the meaning like 100 continue,
the initial part of a request has been received
and has not yet been rejected by the server.
The server intends to send a final response eventually.
And so there's other ones like 200 okay, 201 created.
Let's see, what else should I point out?
304, cache not modified, 400, bad request.
- Bad request.
- 404, not found, 403, forbidden,
500, internal server error.
Yeah, 418, I'm a tbot.
And 502, bad gateway.
Okay, so let's do yours firstly.
- Please.
- I'd put out this joke and you said,
"This is good, but oh my goodness, cats."
- Yeah, so when I was doing my computer science degree,
a friend shared with me HTTP.cat
when we were learning about HTTP status codes.
And if you go there, you will find
one cat per HTTP status code
representing what is going on.
And I'm not going to lie to you,
in my professional career,
I still use it as a reference
because it's my favorite one.
And you can even,
if you go to like HTTP.cat/200,
it returns a JPEG of a cat that's like, okay.
Yeah, exactly.
And you can do that for all of the status codes.
- 201, the cat has walked through some wet cement
and that's too uncreated for footprints.
Let's see what else we got in here.
Some good ones.
404, not modify, 304, sorry.
The 404, the cat is hiding under some wrapping, not found.
Fantastic.
Yeah, I love this.
I had not heard about this and it's glorious.
- Well, wait, is there a 418?
- There is. - Of course there is.
- I mean, teapot.
- A kitten in a teapot.
- Literally inside of a teapot.
All right, so I saw this joke by Breen, who is John Breen,
and thought, that's really funny.
What he did is he put his own personal take
on what status code means,
and I thought they were hilarious,
but I thought, you know, let me take a shot at this as well,
a little more Python focused.
So I, I'll link to my tweet,
I put this set of colloquial meanings
of the HTV status codes.
All right, you all ready for this?
- Yeah.
- Do it.
- So, 200 is, what's up?
All right. All good.
201, hello creator.
304, not modified or cached.
Same old, same old.
403, permission denied.
Get off my lawn, kids.
- That was my favorite.
- 404 is just, there's no message.
It's just not there.
Not that that's the message, but it's just blank.
500 is, we're bad at APIs.
- A little bit. - Server error.
400 is, you're bad at APIs.
- Yes.
- The real cardinal sin of APIs is
200 but in the body there's a JSON that says error and a reason.
- Oof.
- 200 but with error text.
We're really bad at APIs.
- Yeah.
- 502, we're bad at deployment or DevOps because part of the infrastructure can't get to the
other part.
And Brian's favorite, 418.
Is it already April again?
- Yeah.
- Because the reason is that was actually put into the spec as an April Fool's joke and
they left it.
I'm a teapot.
- I love that they left it.
- I do too.
- It's like import this,
just stuff that's fun that should just always be there.
- Yeah. - Yeah.
- What's the harm?
What's the harm?
Just leave it there.
Anthony in the live stream has some feedback for you, Leah.
"HTTP status codes using cats."
Well, I never.
- I mean, where there's internet, there is cats, no?
- Oh, of course.
- Why we created the internet in the first place
is for cats.
- Exactly.
All right, well, I think that's it for our show.
Brian, thanks for being here as always.
Leah, thanks for joining us.
- Thank you for having me.
Thanks for listening, everyone.
- Yeah, you bet.
See y'all later. - Bye.